merci frédéric quelques quelques mots
pour vous présenter ce que vous
représentez ce que vous avez eu donc
vous a parlé notamment philippe tout à
l'heure sur ce que permet les nouveaux
statuts du parti et je veux ici
remercier et saluer le travail de
nathalie kosciusko morizet qui a
travaillé sur ses statuts la partie
moderne transparent
voilà je vais pas être très long mais je
voudrais qu'on conduit reviennent ses
statuts ils ont été validées par bureau
politique du mois de mai ils ont été
votés vous avez voté pour ses statuts
lors du congrès fondateur également à
96% et je pense qu'il ya trois points
importants qui voulait qu'on revoie je
sais pas si ça se si les slides pour
pouvoir passer
il ya trois points c'est d'abord la
parole aux adhérents vous l'avez entendu
on va élire et c'est une nouveauté
le président de la fédération au
suffrage universel direct des adhérents
et ça c'est ce que permet les nouveaux
statuts ce sera donc le samedi 30
janvier 2016
deuxième point important c'est les
votations les votes internes
vous savez on a deux votes qui ont déjà
eu lieu
l'un sur les propositions en matière
d'immigration avec 53 mille adhérents
qui ont qui ont voté et le dernier en
date c'était sur le code du travail et
des propositions en la matière avec 43
mille adhérents qui ont voté y en aura
d'autres il y en aura sur la sécurité
prochainement au niveau national et on
pourrait imaginer à paris on va parler
avec frédéric et philippe et toute
l'équipe pour être tout à fait proposer
des votations sur des sujets parisien
qui pourrait être ensuite débattu au
sein du comité stratégique de nos qui
réunit nos parlementaires et de nos
grands élus
voilà des des choses intéressantes c'est
vous qui allez tranché et aussi à paris
deuxième point important c'est
l'exemplarité des élus et bien à paris
100 % les élus
payent leur cotisation et ça c'était
attendu à la fédération de paris on peut
les remercier
vous savez que dans les statuts aucun
élu qui ne pique il n'a pas payé ses
cotisations ne pourra pas siéger vous
savez sur les institutions dans les
instants les instances locales et
nationales
et ça c'est très important pour
retrouver la crédibilité vous le savez
bien
dernier point important la parité on a
encore un peu de progrès dans l'équipe
qui est présenté ce matin mais
globalement au niveau national il ya des
engagements très forts qui ont été pris
au niveau de la ceni la commission
nationale d'investiture et au niveau du
bureau politique à parité est respectée
le renouvellement aussi fait partie des
engagements dans ses nouveaux statuts
bianchi à l'aria une place qui est faite
aussi aux militants dans toutes les
instances et nicolas sarkozy il était
très attaché voilà les trois points
importants je voulais vraiment souligné
ce matin
et puis on a quelques instants pour vous
donner évidemment mais la parole pour